[Music]  all right let's talk Selena Gomez she  recently celebrated her 26th birthday  and while she took time away from the  spotlight we learned she's found a new  focus both professionally and personally  now is Selena ready to date  we're told she still doesn't feel ready  and while she would love to be in a  relationship in the future she's much  more cautious now  [Music]  our source also says she's incredibly  focused on her career makes me feel  confident 26 year-olds latest project is  the fashion line coach ex Selena Gomez  it's her second collaboration with the  brand figuring out who I was their  passion and being super unapologetic  that's what I find so attractive yeah a  woman who wears it the way she wears it  it just inspires me  [Music]